depuis plusieurs jours l'état dans
lequel se trouve le wanna inquiète de
nombreuses personnes après avoir posté
une vidéo à l'occasion de son
anniversaire dans laquelle l'ancienne
starlette de télé-réalité semblait aller
très mal vécu et une vidéo
loana a posté sur son fil d'actualité
instagram de nombreuses photos de son
corps recouvert d'hématomes des
blessures qu'il impute à de la violence
conjugale en n'hésitant pas à accuser
directement fred cauvin son ex compagnon
le chroniqueur people samira était hier
sur le plateau de thé pmp pour nous
parler d'un appel à l'aide qu'il a
directement au dessus de loana le soir
de son anniversaire la jeune femme lui
aurait proposé de boire de l'alcool elle
mettait dans le message jusqu'à ce que
mort s'ensuive
sur le plateau hier soir nous recevions
également fred cauvin le principal
accusé dans cette affaire il n'a pas
hésité à balancer notamment sur
l'hygiène de vie de loana va au suicide
avec toutes les drogues qu'elle consomme
aujourd'hui ou encore sur sa santé
financière elle m'appelle parce qu'elle
est dans un besoin financièrement une
interview durant laquelle il a reconnu
avoir porté des coups à l'encontre de
loana vous raconter avoir déjà levé la
main sur elle effectivement en mode 2
février
loana a décidé de répondre à ces
polémiques par une vidéo publiée sur
instagram cette nuit une vidéo dans
laquelle elle dénonce le comportement
des hommes violents accouché en fait je
pensais à leur femme
slark en trek est défigurée alors at-on
des nouvelles de loana et on a des
nouvelles de loana loana qui a déjà
partagé des échanges téléphoniques et
visiblement ce heureuse contre 1000
ouanna a partagé des extraits de
messages qui se sont envoyés
suite à l'émission dont une photo assez
explicite d'une jeune femme voilà avec
fred cauvin et kelly vous avez parce que
c'est vrai que cette histoire de loana
tout le monde est choqué par cette
histoire et c'est vrai que c'était là la
petite soeur de tous les français mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est choqué
de la voir comme ça vous l'avez eue au
téléphone n'avait pu la contacter elle
vous a notamment envoyé une vidéo dans
laquelle on peut voir les nombreux
hématomes dont elles souffraient alors
en fait gilles m'a gentiment trouvé son
numéro parce que je l'avais plus je vous
l'avais dit alors elle était ravie que
quelqu'un prenne contact avec elle parce
qu'elle se sent très seul en ce moment
et elle a besoin d' aide elle a vraiment
besoin d'une grande aide
alors elle m'a expliqué un petit peu son
histoire et comment ça s'était passé
donc effectivement on a une vidéo où
elle lui envoie les coûts qui lui
apporter alors on a revu la vidéo
regardez deuxième ça fait presque un
coquard parce que je crois que tu
t'aperçois pas réellement de commentaire
alors je fais en vidéo un regarde c'est
vraiment au dessus du lot y va de soi
et puis ensuite se situe regardez bien
te fais mes jambes de donc la bonde
hématome la bombe à tourner jusqu'à
filles tv aussi à la cuisse lui il est
comment sa double là aussi voilà alors
alors alors ça si je peux me permettre
c'était une vidéo qu'elle avait fait
trois semaines après donc ça s'est passé
cet été et ensuite elle est partie en
vacances pour un peu prendre l'air il
n'a pas récupéré les clés de son
appartement il a pris possession des
lieux de son appartement pendant cet été
et l'a foutu le bazar mais complet et on
a une vidéo ou qui prouve le bazar qui
lui a encore le bazar depuis cet été
nommée elle avait fait des vidéos de cet
été et on a une vidéo qui montre le
bazar qu'il a laissé alors là qu'est ce
qui se passe à de vieilles pâte bien
moisi ensuite nous avons le coin
vaisselle avec les trucs qui pourrissent
encore à l'intérieur une poubelle
ensuite on commence à râler deux
pouvaient ensuite des winners pourquoi
je pense que c'est son patin qui devait
dormir ici alors loana elle ne souhaite
pas le poursuivre en justice un fred
cauvin gilles verde oui lui seul ait eu
donc il maintient sa plainte en
diffamation vous parlez d'une photo qui
a été diffusée par loana le fret cauvin
avec une femme lui dit que c'est une
photo qui date d'un an donc et pas du
tout une photo après son passage
il dit que là je donne sa version i dit
que loana n'a pas supporté son passage
dans l'émission et que du coup il ya eu
tout un acharnement qui changeait du ton
de la veille et il dit voilà maintenant
le mot qu'il a employé ses nous sommes
en guerre tous les deux on verra
jusqu'où ça ira mais je maintiens ma
plainte
alors moi j'ai la réponse de l'âne de
loana a ce truc là alors loana me dit
que c'était une photo qui était la
veille pour le prévenir qu'il allait
venir sur le plateau et qu'il allait et
ensuite j'ai une info au niveau 2
à givet capture d'écran de la réponse du
du mec c'est bon on va pas non plus
rentrer là dedans là les chéris je pense
que loana elle avait prévenu quand même
qu'elle portait pas plainte
oui ce qu on m a donné les raisons oui
mais c'est possible voilà les raisons
les raisons c'est qu'en fait elle est
follement attaché à ses enfants et elle
veut absolument pas leur causer des
torts et voir leur père derrière les
barreaux ou voilà elle veut pas faire
subir ça aux enfants mais elle m'a
précisé qu'elle n'était plus sous son
emprise et qu'elle voulait juste vivre
tranquille et qu'il fallait qu'il la
laisse tranquille
mais bon on espère qu'il valait mieux et
c'est vrai qu'il as tranquille que tout
le monde se laisse tranquille